nous devons d'accepter immédiatement 25
mille réfugiés syriens
ça c'était au milieu de la campagne de
2015 se souvient le monde entier avait
réagi après la photo du petit dylan
curdy jeanne ouedraogo nous demande
pouvez vous nous donner l'heure juste
sur le nombre de réfugiés qui sont
entrés depuis 2015 on sait qu'il en est
rentré beaucoup plus que 25000 d'aucuns
parlent d'au moins 55 milles alors
d'abord est-ce que la promesse a été
tenue et assami oui nous dit cet expert
de l'université de calgary et justin
trudeau n'a pas manqué de faire partie
du comité d'accueil le 25 millièmes
réfugiés syriens est arrivé le 28
février 2016 et en tout entre la
promesse libérale et aujourd'hui ce sont
quarante cinq mille réfugiés syriens qui
sont venus s'installer ici on parle de
ceux qui étaient dans des camps comme
celui ci au liban ça ne concerne pas les
demandeurs d'asile qui viennent frapper
à notre porte comme auch maroc ram et
oui ça n'était jamais arrivé que le
canada soit le premier pays d'accueil au
monde
c'est surtout dû au fait que les états
unis en fond moi beaucoup moins depuis
2003 regardez en bleu les états unis en
rouge le canada les cours se sont
croisés l'année dernière et ça va
s'accentuer en 2020 les états unis
prévoit 18 milles au nord de la
frontière
trente-deux mille
enfin ce serait bien de savoir combien
ça nous coûte 2 mondial au cas où
environ 20 mille dollars par réfugiés
selon robert falconer qui assure revues
scientifiques à l'appui qu'un réfugié ne
coûte pas plus cher en prestations
sociales qu'un canadiens dans le besoin
mais surtout ils finissent par
rembourser ses traits en travaillant et
en payant des impôts